let's talk about the lighthouse I saw
this film and I was blown away by it and
II you saw the film well amazing it's
it's an amazing film and it is
generating I don't know if you're one of
the kind of person that doesn't like to
hear this but it is generating a lot of
Oscar buzz does that make you nervous
when you hear that or thanks breakers
over the years some people don't say
that it's a jinx and you're just like
bring it on no no I'm okay
yeah also it's a small movie so it's
important that it gets out there so
whatever recognition it gets helps for
people to be aware of it yeah yeah it's
absolutely I've not seen a film like
this it is and without giving away too
much because I don't want anybody to
much but it's very simply a story about
two guys who are stranded pretty much at
a lighthouse 1890s in the Northeast on
this craggy coast and it looks miserable
it's like a miserable location yeah
because I'll tell you I was fortunate
enough to talk to the great Michael
Caine a number of years ago and he was
telling me that he he would choose a
movie based on the description of like
oh if it's in the South of France I'll
shoot the movie you don't I mean if it
takes place on a tropical beach I'll
shoot the movie this is like you have
the opposite philosophy you're shooting
this on a craggy rock in what looks like
the least Pleasant weather waves
crashing sea weed slime why it's all
there you don't have to have yeah yeah
yeah cold you're cold yeah oh
really good that's a good point so cuz
you do a great job of looking truly wet
and miserable and I think they're you
were wet miserable yeah was it that
stormy I mean first of all though it was
we enhanced it sometimes yeah they have
things that water cannons that are these
big things that throw this huge amount
of water at you
it was pretty miserable yeah it's part
of it I mean joke all joking aside yeah
um you know the weather was a big part
of it because it's really these two guys
in the elements yeah
and you are what is interesting about it
too is that I think we've all been in
situations where we've had a roommate
that made us a little crazy yeah there's
a there's a part of this film that's
that is very relatable where your two
guys that are quite different and you've
got to share this space together and
luck there and you're stuck there and
you just see the two of you grappling
with there is nowhere to go
we're you know this is and and and the
madness that ensues yeah but I think
people see it many different they
project many different things you know
they predict all of their relationships
on it whether it's a boss employee
father's son that's a grim portrait of
marriage this is why my wife and I have
one summer we rented a white house
together it didn't work out well and
hence the movie it was the basis of the
movie uh there is such your character is
this great old sea salt right and it's
eighteen late eighteen it's 1890 and
he's this great sea salt and one of the
things he does is he is his job is to
establish dominance he's the guy running
in the lighthouse Robert Pattinson shows
up so he's got to show dominance yeah
right away and you've got all these some
great some kind of crass ways of
establishing dominance over his
character like he's the newbie and
you're the guy who really runs that's
right and you're talking about me
corralling him with farts
it's a no that's not that's not where I
was going but you do bring it no no hey
well it is true that's there are a lot
of different ways that you established
Dominus but that is one of the things
your character does right away to Robert
Pattinson character which is your way of
saying I run things around here it was
in the script not my idea I'm just
submitting to the directors will no no
no no no they teach you how to fart on
command at Julliard it's that and
clowning like you got a juggle fart on
command you have these incredible
speeches I mean one of the reasons I
think there's just been you you always
give a great performance and there are
times where the camera is is right up in
your face and you were giving this
incredible performance and these
speeches where you can your insults you
have these these great 1890s sort of New
England and they seem so authentic sort
of c-captain insults that just seem too
real
yes beautiful writing and it's you know
it's rare that in a film you get poetic
you know elevated land yeah yeah and it
was built very much from drawing for
things from Melville and Milton and and
also you know various sources of
literature at that time yeah so it's
kind of stitched together but there's
some beautiful expressions and what's
nice is it's so colorful to work on
because it's got such vivid imagery
images and then when I'm you know trying
to humiliate him or dominate him or
whatever's going on yeah
it's it's very specific yeah it's much
more powerful than you know kind of flat
naturalistic language there's a there's
a there's a there's a moment where you
you say you're insulting him and you
tell him that you smell like a curdled
foreskin and I wrote that one I'm down
I'm like I've got to remember that if
I'm ever angry you know
thanks for the image hey wait a minute
no is it your movie he said it yeah but
I left it behind you know I couldn't
stop thinking about it there's another
one make the light you you're telling
him to clean up the white house though
the light at the white house Freud would
have a field day with what this happened
you say you wanted to clean up the
lighthouse and you say make the
lighthouse sparkle like a sperm whale's
pecker
you're like spits ha it's really
fantastic language just amazing amazing
writing also some zoological information
I did not know